remember when Gwyneth Paltrow did the
vagina scented candle which by the way
the crazy thing about that smelled like
heat stick around
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population Wardell
random
I'm feeling great I like I like to
reopen we come in and we just hot dude
there it is
he opened a can of dumb oh Lord I was
just watching early episodes if I think
you should leave love seeing you show up
whoa thank you I was like oh yeah I
forgot about it I was like hey oh yeah
I'm in that a couple times dude he was
phenomenal in Easter Sunday
I loved him in that movie let's talk
about him like he's not here yeah I
loved him in that movie whenever I see
Brandon such a shame we're getting
third-person interviews I can't believe
I can't believe he fell off so hard I
wonder how he felt when he did that yeah
well there's no way we'll ever know
there's no way no you were great in that
Jay Sandra sakar he's fantastic I love
that movie and I thought you were really
good Lou Diamond Phillips come on oh
yeah Cameo there I watched him uh learn
what Tide Pods are oh and then like in
real time yeah like I watched him like
find a bag of Tide Pods and like that we
were all staying in like the same yeah
say not the same apartment but the same
floor of the same yeah apartment
building apartment and uh I watched him
find a bag of Tide Pods and go like what
is this what is this and he was like Dr
everybody was drunk of course yeah it's
like ldp
um like five drinks deep finding out
what a type I I had to like explain to
him what a tide pod is you just go
horrible for the environment yeah I I
didn't I didn't explain any of the yeah
environmental ramifications or anything
any of the viral stuff A couple of years
ago or you just keep going like ethereal
he's like yeah but what is it you're
like exactly exactly what is it I don't
even know how it works man I don't know
I mean how do they get the swirl I by
the way I do I did I did notice uh you
have the The Bob Newhart vinyl sure yes
on display in the back which I really
like because I did
um when I was on my 16th birthday I
asked my parents to take me to see Bob
Newhart yeah you did great gift like
this kid's going into
I was like I really need to see Bob
Newhart 15.
yeah 15 going on yeah my favorite
Jennifer Garner movie continue going on
70s she's a movie you could make I want
him to make 15 going on 70 with Bob new
uh although I don't think Bob he's like
96. uh so yeah is he still alive
how old do you think he is I want to say
94. uh so 91. so here's the deal the
world is dumber and I and I love that
like the Lou Diamond Phillips story is a
great story because you're like stars
and really famous people I feel like
don't have basic knowledge right like
they don't like they're shielded away
from the day-to-day stuff well actors
are often times the dumbest people well
it's like it's also uh kind of
incentivized with the job he's 90.
not saying that with reference to uh ldp
no he's other other activities but
actors
like by and large yes you know hey you
know let's get let's get those residuals
let's get to the let's get all that [__]
settled but actors oftentimes some of
the dumbest [__] out of touch
out of touch with three hours out of
touch with reality on it it rewards
being like a a blank space you know like
how do you like a golden retriever that
you're going around right yeah I'll do a
teaching that trick right exactly all
right so I'm gonna jump into the story I
would love to act more yeah when the
strike is over we'll make that happen
all right uh this may be my favorite
headline of all time sent in by Eric
James hiltner at
ejh3k and of course all of us are part
of the Hilton Honors program of course
all right you ready for this I I can't
believe this story and even as I read it
I cannot believe that this happened or
how it happened put it this way I'm
looking at this story the way Lou
Diamond Phillips looked at a bag of time
okay I'm like how how what is it here's
the headline pet fish commits credit
card fraud on owner using Nintendo
switch what say it one more time pet
fish commits credit card fraud on owner
using a Nintendo switch hi Mad Libs I no
that's not possible in a Freak series of
seemingly random events this is
reopening of Magnolia yeah
that's more like smart Fish Town yeah
yeah smart Fish Town great show a switch
owners pet fish accessed his eShop
account and added funds to it using his
credit card how how wouldn't also the
fish forget every 12 seconds right so it
kept on adding that's right did I buy
this oh my God every fish is in Memento
that was my that was my wife when she
did stand up years ago that was one of
her bits was like the fish seeing like a
swimming around and staying and just
being like there was like a little diver
next to the castle and the fish would
come around and be like hi diver sure
was that considered fraud
I don't know that's a great question so
here's the fish wasn't yeah
it's like nefarious thank you motivation
so Brandon bringing up the point that
intent is half the best graduated law
school
the crime was caught on video during an
unsupervised life that's even Wilder
hundreds of viewers watched as the
little fish stole their owner's identity
while he was gone wow wait what is this
streaming on this switch twitch the
entire Heist started as an experiment to
see if the fish could complete Pokemon
scarlet and violet unassisted I'm gonna
be honest with you Randy I don't know I
have yet to understand any sentence
you've said in this story to do it
Japanese YouTuber okay
Maru channels that's right YouTuber set
up a webcam focused on his Fishbowl
motion tracking software monitored the
fish as they swam across an overlaid
grid populated with controller inputs if
a Fish Paws or change directions the
correlating controller input registered
in the game so you kind of set this up
for them exactly
steal your identity muteki Maru had done
this experiment before this is
essentially like the nerdiest game of
stop hitting yourself
or right right but you've you're doing
to yourself yeah the Japanese version of
the new season of squid game all right
his fish successfully completed the task
finishing Pokemon Sapphire no he didn't
his fish moved around how many hours did
it take for the fish to finish Pokemon
Sapphire how many hours what do you
think six Jay I mean they're constantly
moving four what do you think with the
finished Pokemon sound like each way it
moves each way it corresponds to a
movement that the game does it get like
it's wired yeah so when did it move
enough times in a certain pattern I mean
how long does it take a human to finish
that game more than six hours I don't
know yeah I thought it was one task the
whole game it's like a long wow the
whole game I mean there's a whole days I
don't know I don't know like finish a
game I'm gonna go I'm gonna go 37 hours
I'm gonna assume it's like a 12 hours
what did you say Jay four hours I said
four hours I'm waiting like I'm I'm
gonna say uh 40 hours okay I'm gonna go
39 hours 39 hours yeah how many hours
three thousand one hundred okay see yeah
so okay then what the [__] more than
four said way more but I actually I have
the correct answer
like yeah it takes people days weeks
right okay but so yeah you were the
closest
yeah thank you this is our like uh our
current timelines uh chimpanzees in a
room riding Hamlet that's it that's it
that's 100 I'm gonna take them you can't
credit them with it right so how many
hours does it take this according to
this uh on average to beat the game just
a regular human to do it what did you
say before I'll still I still like my
God 36 hours 36 hours what do you think
a regular person to complete it to
complete the game yeah oh I'm gonna
actually say like last two weeks two
weeks Last of Us is like the 10 12 hours
87 hours okay 30 hours okay however this
time around things did not go quite as
planned the identity theft occurred when
muteki Maru was away from the YouTube
live stream uh the game went swimmingly
yeah
stop with the fish winning several
battles at the one hour
140 for the 144 hour mark the game
crashed as games sometimes do but
without muteki Maro present to fix the
situation the system continued
registering inputs from the fish right
eventually the pesky little critters got
to the Nintendo issue just like when
your cat walks across the keyboard
that's right no but this is like what
program devices
I get it now so the game crashed but the
fish are still moving and it's still
hooked up to it right so it rebooted
right how like like every time you have
to restart your computer Dropbox where
you open so you're like get the [__] out
of here drop so it reboots and then
eShop comes up twice and entirely by
chance registered the correct sequence
event sequence of inputs to add how much
yen how much yen did it add so this is
also when you guess a gift card number
yes
I think it put in there uh uh 10 000 Yen
what do you think five thousand what do
you think uh twenty thousand yeah it put
500 yen which is about approximately how
many in US Dollars yes a currency
converter I don't know 500. strong right
now I don't know just take a guess
500 yen is how many dollars eighty seven
dollars I was gonna say 80 bucks 80
bucks what do you think 90 bucks it's
four dollars four dollars oh yeah I see
I have no idea what yeah
total identity this is a smart fish too
he stole four dollars for me mateki
maru's account from his credit card that
was saved on the switch they also
exposed his credit card information to
everyone watching [__] girl great it
deserves good yeah that to me I teach
you to be a YouTuber information this
should be the story of Finding Nemo
three am I right yes buying Nemo then
the Scoundrels managed to use some of
the fighting
tomorrow's accumulated reward points to
purchase a new avatar download the N64
emulator get PayPal to send him in the
words of Joe pantoliano from Goonies I'm
starting to like this fish I really am
starting to like this fish and change
that his Nintendo account name from mute
that's what they changed it to the what
if the fish had somehow typing so you
kind of how this happened is he like
left left yeah
is doing all these motions and it's
setting off and it's like because
essentially he's essentially made it so
that if the fish goes left that counts
as a left click on a mouse if the fish
goes right that and so it's just do you
want to change your password
yes right right
what if
the fish had written out like I had a
family please help me get back home like
the fishes like like was that the
gorilla Coco yeah it was like oh we
taught it sign language and then it
depressed us all because it was able to
tell us how [__] up this is in this
case stop treating me this way
all right anyway so uh the fish
free-fall went on for how many hours how
many hours did this go on I mean here's
the other thing his streams were
probably through the roof because once
you're watching a fish hack into
somebody's system are you gonna stop I
mean you're so pot committed I would say
his swim his streams were swimming
Upstream
for all of the fish word play I'm not
I'm surprised nobody's gone with the pH
oh I know come on
if you were watching this wouldn't it
kind of feel like the end of Truman Show
I mean you'd be like come on fish get
out would it also kind of feel like the
middle of a fish concert
aimlessly moving around in multiple
directions what's the point of this yeah
um okay how many what was how many hours
did the fish free for all take place
well it's until he comes back home
because he doesn't realize so how long
six hours okay four seven hours one of
you [__] exactly right that's me six
you're gonna hang with us
get your answers in town is because
Brandon Wardell is absolutely right
seven hours
seven hour free for all okay before the
future bait finally managed to power
down the switch uh muteki Maru contact
and Nintendo explaining what happened
that must have been a fun conversation
no so what happened was a fish attacked
my identity the most [__] hey at
least he has a proof yeah he actually
did have streaming he asked for a refund
of his 500 yen hilariously enough
Nintendo granted the request good on
Nintendo actually yeah to believe this
guy like who PS5 would have kept that
[__]
[__] so all said and done nothing was
lost truly except uh how many points for
an avatar how many points did he lose
for a new Avatar what does that mean you
have to
yeah it cost points
250 points I don't know you know the
fortnite system Dave what is it yeah
it's the skin how much money would you
say you're in to fortnite so I probably
spent all in if you really had to guess
it's not and I understand it counts as a
gift you bought your son again
it's probably like 2K no three more like
800 maybe a thousand oh that's that's
moderate over the course of six years
he's probably he's probably guessing low
but whatever we're like fortnite DLC
yeah yeah okay yeah all right so Jay
what
um I'm gonna say I said 250. yeah you
said 250 what do you think 1000.
uh one thousand one there yeah uh 10
points for an avatar okay take the W no
why did I say a thousand no I shouldn't
no 10. no harm no foul I'm surprised you
didn't say no harm all of the currency
conversion it's it's I know I know I'm
failing this act it's okay no harm no no
flounder is what I expected this is the
lessons of the article and it is so
morbid I just don't even understand it
hopefully uh muteki Maro sees it that
way too and doesn't flush the little
thieves down the toilet
flushing it fishing on the toilet by the
way it doesn't kill it I mean it just
puts it in the sewer system which will
probably die if you leave your toddler
sitting next to a bucket of paint yeah
whatever happens when you've come back
into the room he's not on that not on
the top you create a system for your
fish to be able to control your computer
and you leave it on that's right Dan
this is a metaphor for AI what we're
dealing with right now yes you give that
fish to much power it will dominate your
life
Daniel got the second story I'll be back
with more dumb people town uh and find
out what we're doing right after this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into Story number two quick plugs
for us uh uh when this drops we might
have a tag it in the middle of uh August
it's such a fun show it's so fun have
you ever done tag
post a show yeah Comics come up do their
set and then some Comics like Nikki did
stuff she wanted tags forward you're so
smart of her yeah you did also and at
the end they come out on stage with you
and what normally happens in The Green
Room for us we just we do one stage
it's so fun it's so collaborative it
shows the comedies collaborative so
we're doing that and then uh in January
or January Jesus Christ in September
we'll be in Ann Arbor Michigan at the
Ann Arbor comedy showcase the eighth and
9th all our dates are on superscars.com
check all that out join our patreons Mr
Wardell what about you oh well the
Brandon Jamel shows my is my podcast
nice
and then I will be I'll be on the road I
think in like the Midwest in September
okay
it's all on so social media well you
know yeah go there where can people
follow you uh Instagram I guess BS
Wardell I'm not I'm not really on
Twitter I guess you had one of my
favorite tweets of all time though which
one
um
it was something like where you know
where you you're doing diet like a tweet
where you're doing dialogue and the
person was like you wrote the person
saying how come you won't text me back
but I see you writing tweets and then
you wrote Because those are different
energies baby oh I don't know yeah I
don't know what the what I loved that
tooth because it's also true it is
my energy that I'm putting into like
joking around or being an idiot on the
internet is not the same as me writing
you back about whatever whatever loading
question yes I just loved it I would
have tweeted
that text
and just that side of the text that says
why do you why won't you text me when I
see her tweeting and then in the tweet I
would have underneath it said because
I'm bit
are you guys ready for a story too let's
do it story too
disgusted oh this was sent in by Matthew
Friedman at not your AVG Matt with two
T's not your average Matt uh disgusted
customer claims mac and cheese candle
smells horrid well bought a mac and
cheese Candle by the way I think it
would smell great I've had I bought
bread candles before remember what I
smell like red who's making so that
sounds like Tom Papa's merch that's
right you're right so there was a candle
store in St Louis when my kids were
little we went to like okay this is
already crazy Randy because it means it
it posits that you were someone on a
trip going I'm gonna buy this candle and
take it home no I was like on the road
what are we going to do with these kids
and then are like let's go to a candle
store I'm like that'll kill a few hours
that's what I want and your spirit and
then but there are moments where I'm
there's the candles in our room and it's
like we've never lit it never smells
like bread it smells like bread remember
when Gwyneth Paltrow did the vagina
scented candle which by the way the
crazy thing about that smelled like
yeast no that's the difference
with the bread wait tell me more was it
good it smells like it's a candle that
smells like bread you liked it yes I
loved it but it's like the I I don't
know how do you get a idea of like I
like the idea of freshly baked bread
promise of bread you're oh I'm about to
eat bread so you only like the bread
with the result that comes with it yeah
I don't want to just smell the bread
without like oh
is there bread on the horizon they do
candles that smell like fresh baked
cookies and I'm like why are you [__]
with it yeah I smell bread surely there
must
fresh baked bread yeah in my very near
future so in here because they're
smelling and then I and then now I'm
Crest falling because there's no it's
just goddamn bread that's right wait
crust that stinks Dan you said I heard
you under your breast Say Jimmy John's
yeah I promise you I promise you
whatever that Jim Jones is Not bread no
if you laid out for me a Jimmy John
sandwich and a Jersey Mike sandwich and
I didn't know which was which and you
you could smell the difference no you
said tell me which is which I promise
you I could never tell you the
difference oh I bet you you could in a
million years which one is better is
Jimmy John's better than Jersey the
Rosemary parm Jersey Mike's bread is so
[__] okay so where at Jersey Mike's
yes
but Jimmy John's Jeremy Johnson I
thought Jimmy Johnson when you eat it it
always wants to shoot out the back
because I well I've I I think like
in either in either case I I will say
like the original sub debate yeah like
of 20 years sure yeah it's crazy what's
happened to both of the subway yeah
which is I was I never really liked
Subway it's an airport sandwich the age
of like yeah 12 yeah yeah even so you
could probably find better stuff sure
sure maybe or it's like if you're in
like a town where there's like truly
nothing
uh and like I but Quiznos dude quiz
notes have you seen what happened
oh there's like 100 Quiznos left yes in
the country they're becoming extinct I
don't understand they need to be
protected like the bald eagle yeah I
don't I swear to God there's like less
than 200 Quiznos that exists
oh yeah one piece no but it was on Air
Force bases that I lived at yeah yeah
like it was like sure like every Air
Force Base would have
one Burger King and one Blimpy I can't
believe you were in the Air Force as
such a little kid yeah yeah yeah what he
has on The Bob Hope scholarships
paratrooper I was a fighter pilot no but
then meanwhile there's Firehouse Subs
okay here's just like smoking in the
corner
oh dude I actually am I'm actually so
glad that you [__] brought a
Firehouse Subs because you've uh I saw a
firehouse subhead that made me want to
eat all of it they do it the pepperoni
pizza sub that is it's in this like
YouTube thing in the u-shaped bread is
[__] garlic bread
okay Firehouse Subs is a place I went to
a lot during my brief uh during my scent
at Northern Community Northern Virginia
Community College before I eventually
transferred to Virginia Commonwealth
University dropped out sure gotcha but
during my Cent at NOVA community college
I would go to Firehouse Subs a lot for
sure and it's like yeah it's like pretty
good okay it was pretty good and they
had a Coca-Cola Freestyle machine right
which was like really big for me because
I also I could only drink uh diet sodas
so I'm I'm diabetic so I can't have like
right full sugar sorry and usually the
only option Diet Coke Coca-Cola
Freestyle that was like it was new it
was like a new Coca-Cola whatever you
want man so I was like geeked on that I
would go to the Coca-Cola Freestyle
machine website enter in my ZIP code and
then just you know where can I go who's
who's who's got me who's got to say
who's got me today but Firehouse Subs
the thing about Firehouse Subs is they
have
like framed photos
throughout the restaurant of just like
houses on fire yeah I know that's right
so those are controlled Burns so I don't
know about that when we went to the at
the diner
Sparks Diner up by your cabin in in
Wisconsin yeah there were pictures of
houses burning and firefighters smiling
in front of it we're like you guys
should be going to fight there they're
losing their possessing that's a post
game yeah don't do that it'll save them
you guys might leave early before the
Firestone while we're all here
it's not wheel the podium out in the
third quarter like every Grandma at a
birthday while we're all here while
we're all here okay so my thing about
Quiznos is because they're an endangered
sub shop now I think there should be
Quiznos in every Zoo because you're like
yeah
it wouldn't this Quizno wouldn't survive
out in the wild it couldn't do it on its
own but I will tell you this someone
tried to capriotti
a repulse customer had had blasted a
candle making company for selling a
candle they claimed smells like a fart
left trapped in a bag for 50 years since
night's so specific what if it's what if
someone's mother was like this smells
like about 40 48 years yeah don't don't
be saying since 1996 a us-based company
DW home has been selling all sorts of
unusual scented candles including now
this is food that would piss me off just
like you said about the bread mashed
potatoes okay turkey dinners sure and
mac and cheese mac and cheese if I walk
into somebody's house well and I can
[__] smell a turkey dinner yeah and
they're like oh no it's just the candle
I'd be like this I think what you're
tapping into here is uh the the
sensation of
um somebody walking in with hot food
onto an airplane yes yeah because it's
like it's all food it's food that if you
smelled it in a non-plain context right
yeah yeah plain is a different Universe
like the traps land rules don't apply so
you can't you're not eat it you're not
eating I want to watch a guy in a play
Just housing Bonito flakes crazy which
is just the most of the smells Okay so
certain smells Jay and I were just in
San Francisco at Cobbs Comedy Club next
all who came out for that great next
great place next door like right down
the street between Cobbs and the Corner
Bar that I love so much you know that oh
yeah it's like it's an Irish bar like
there it's so cool right on the corner
like that's where we hang post show
that's a little secret pre and post show
uh in between there a Curry House
the smell is coming through that place
it was it was so good and I can't tell
you if the food was good I just smelled
that we walked by and we're like oh my
God this is a like they they don't need
signs they don't need advertising and it
was you could tell it was like a cool
hip thing but smells are a big deal this
is actually a really big so they're mad
at the mac and cheese flake because it
smells like a fart in a bag for 50. when
you walk past the barbecue place it was
like a craft branded I got that right no
because I'm pretty sure they've done
they've they do that sometimes
this is I think just a Mac and okay DW
mac and cheese so you're probably going
with a you're probably going with a
you're probably going with like a baked
it's probably a baked yeah
yeah I know I don't know this is what
this is okay no I I think this is what
they deserve however one disgusting
December one disgusted customer has been
left less than impressed by the mac and
cheese offering claiming it left them
gagging in horror and in need of
marriage counseling oh come on relax
customers claims they'd initially
believed their husband had soiled
himself after getting a whiff of the
candle which they say nearly caused them
to projectile vomit so the husband
farted right and was like it's the
candle babe
also I want to blame it on the candle
right and she was like we'll talk about
this at couples therapy the nauseated
customer whose name is Taylor said you
all deserve jail time my husband was
giggling like a six-year-old boy as I
gagged in horror now I'm convinced he is
drunk and soiled himself but no he's
sober is he and just stupidly laughing
at the candle Choice surprise he was
waiting for me so he knew it smelled bad
it was like yeah dude it's the giggle
gag
you gotta watch out for the giggle gag
man love but if it was going to be
crafted has to be spirals spiral candle
is where I'm where I live would you get
a candle that smelled like a wet dog no
no no I no I wouldn't do that no but it
sounds unpleasant after a good
shampooing smells so nice you like the
smell of a wet dog no oh well I
understand like other bad smelling
candles there could be a company right
definitely I'm sure there's a company
that will create bad smell can yeah like
mop or you know the strawberry salt on
throw up at a school
thank you thank you okay
when he giggled and told me it was mac
and cheese candle that was causing me to
almost projectile vomit I slammed the
lid in it to smother the flame and ran
it out to the trash can we literally had
to open the windows and leave the house
to go get dinner hopefully they got mac
and cheese whoever made
owes me marriage counseling that's not
why you need it jail time it wasn't the
only buyer to take issue with this
particular scent okay which what do you
think its rating is which has a rating
on the official DW home website what do
you think the rating is of this candle
mac and cheese out of five out of five
stars you wanna go first TIG or last one
okay
yeah I'm gonna go two stars okay three
stars and if you are taking the time to
rate products on the DWP website or
whatever it is
it has a rating of 4.6 okay okay so most
people like it a second person shuttered
it smells like someone dumped the mac
and cheese flavor powder into a bag
farted and it sealed up the bag and then
you opened it we already covered this
it's epic however all the things that
had to do you got to dump the powder and
we got to open the bag sounds like
someone tried to dump it into a bag and
then got a phone call so they waited a
few minutes and then once they then they
clicked over to another call because
they had to deal with someone else and
then they came back and they're like oh
yeah what was I doing oh yeah it's in
this bag I got a fart in this bag fart
in the bag but then they were like oh
[__] I gotta remember I gotta pick up
the dog that's down at the vet and it's
like oh my God ready already right oh my
God I just remembered I said something
horrible with my aunt once when I was
seven let me write her a writer and
actually should I write her a note or
sure you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna text her apologize and then block
her because you know what I mean I'll
chill her out see if she remembers it
deal her out out not up okay
however there are others who can't get
enough of this fragment which one happy
customer praised as being astounding
artisanal achievement another gushed
I did not this is for you Brandon I did
not expect this to smell identical to
boxed mac and cheese what but it does
I'm back on board whoever created this
got it exactly right amazing DW sells
nearly
650 different cents
including warm tobacco pipe that could
be good
that smells good that smells good but so
here's the thing Dan you know the person
who's like it smells like artisanal mac
and cheese no that's a jerk so that
person it smells like box mac and cheese
but someone else called it an astounding
artisanal achievement right fine and I
was starting outstanding artisanal
achievement but that person loves to say
to the people who think it thinks that
it stinks you don't get it yeah
you're not seeing it surely the truth
lies somewhere in the middle right yes
or 4.6 parts of my elders and artisanal
are artisanal magic outstanding artistic
achievement yes I would call it I would
call it fartisinal maybe the name of
this episode is outstanding artisanal
achievement or partisanal achievement
partisan is pretty great uh so they sell
uh other cents of their 650 like warm
tobacco pipe tranquil Lotus and lava I
will ask you they go for about how much
U.S dollars 50 50 bucks I think the
candle is 36 36. oh wait actually I'm
Gonna Change let me change my answer
yeah because 50 is I think that they're
going low I think it's like sort of a
low ball it's not a Yankee Candle
yeah this is we're not talking diptych
right sure
35 35 okay what'd you say I said 36.
I'll switch mine at 27. okay uh 1999. in
U.S dollars it equals
19.30
nice all right we also have our third
story give us a team I just want to say
that I'm kind of anti-food candles yeah
yes you agreed I know because the
promise of what you're smelling is not
gonna come too if I walk in and it
smells like pie and your oven's not even
on but the sweet treat ones is that's
not any any desserty candle it's not
even about the Strawberry Shortcake yeah
it's just kind of I don't I don't know
if I walk in and it's barbecue chicken
though I'd be like who's making chicken
no one Daniel it's a candle that's right
uh all right here's what's a little
teaser of what we're gonna get in
section uh you you don't always need to
post everything that happens in your
life great point it's a great real whole
life although if he someone ever says
why are you not texting me you gotta
post that you have to post oh yeah I
don't even remember I actually don't
remember certain people I remember that
was like
barely use it now I like don't really
use it sure but I used to when I was
like 23 yeah I would like it's a long
time ago
and like tweet 20 times a day and not
like I yeah it's I look back on it now
and I'm like thank God you weren't like
drunk Tweety all right crazy uh all
right well let's take a break we come
back and uh Dan will tell us what he's
up to and then we'll get into this life
story it's not people Town Brandon
Wardell don't go anywhere
[Music]
all right hey guys welcome back to the
show Daniel where can people see you and
support you guys here's a couple I'll
give you a couple of highlights first
everything's up at danielvankirk.com or
at Daniel Van Kirk uh I've got some real
fun announcements for great things
coming up soon that I can't say but what
I can say is in September I think like
the 21st ish right around then I'll be
at the high plains Comedy Festival and
it's so fun in October I think on the
20th I'm doing an 8 o'clock show at the
white bowl and that is I'm headlining
yuck Fest can I do your 11 11 uh thing
11 11 at the Lincoln Lodge in uh Chicago
Illinois you're a dance recording
Especial a new special it'll be my album
would be my special so come on out I
think because we're shooting the whole
thing in the second show I might be
doing some stuff from thanks Diane just
to get it on film because do I not have
it anywhere but uh it'll be my it'll be
my new it's a great hour and my new
album that's 11 11 at the Lincoln Lodge
make it a weekend and I guarantee there
will be some sort of official or
unofficial party at one of my favorite
bards afterwards as well so we can come
hang out meet raffle dance yeah meet
raffle RJ bring us home all right this
is sent in by Jake Roney at jaycaroni
love you Jake biker who tried to get
away from GSP identified after he posted
video of Chase to tick tock wait George
St-Pierre YouTube The Fighter yeah who's
Jasmine okay wait that headline one more
time to try to get away from Georgia
State Police identified after he posted
video of Chase to Tick-Tock in YouTube
so he's dummy you got away
like you don't even understand that like
post it to someone else's account he
wanted the view although it would still
probably be first person
right I mean like yeah
they're gonna find him so POV you're
running yeah
that feel that feeling you get when the
cops are chasing you all right yeah POV
you had a bad day all right don't do
that to the Clayton County Police
Department has issued arrest warrants
for Riverdale motorcyclists after
officers said he alluded police piece
during a Chase and then posted his
exploits on social media dummy you got
away dip [__] so Jay and I were in we're
walking back from in San Francisco
walking back to the hotel just walking
back from Saturday night and we and we
were literally talking to our friend we
said you know they're talking about how
San Francisco is in a post-apocalyptic
mad house
we're not seeing it looks so cool I'm
literally rolling like our merch down in
my like rolling back talking to
everybody Andrew Cohen and we're walking
down and he's like whoa whoa whoa you
see something he's like stop stop stop
and we're like what it's like people
running people running and they were
like what are you saying three days
three young Jews are running down the
street kind of on the Block right in
front of us cop car pulls up they
disperse like three guys
one runs through through us like right
between the three we're like what is
happening and they're going every which
way and then they start running back to
this way and a cop like tackles one and
takes down on the street it was just it
was so insane I'm like why did you run
exactly towards the cop car yeah and
that it'd be like somebody filming it
yeah yeah the guy running away one of
them got away two of them I think got
caught right one got caught up the
street and then one got away be like
that guy posting that video on Tick Tock
if you post that video on things like
you also have dumb friends because I
guarantee to one of his friends he was
like dude should I post it well that's
like they're probably like yeah this has
been something that's been happening for
I feel like I see this story every
couple of months yeah that was like a
big Facebook live thing yeah right I'm
gonna Facebook live and go live and it's
like we can Geo Target where you are now
so uh after hearing about the case
Lieutenant riemers with the Clayton
County Police Department began searching
social media and eventually found the
video so cops now I have to act like
people who had their bikes stolen yeah
where you go on to Craigslist or offer
up or Marketplace and be like is someone
selling my bike part of a cops now
detective work is like well I'm gonna go
social media and see if anybody if they
posted them running from us right right
right right actually I have I've
incriminated myself once okay and this
is I've I've told this story on a
different podcast but I
like I I was uh I Vaped on a on a
JetBlue flight once and
um this is actually this is me being
very dumb person yeah yeah this is your
dumb people Town story I I [__] I
like I don't know I was like off like a
Zan and like like had drank on the plane
tweeting a lot and uh then I was like in
the I'm in the bathroom and then I I
posted some photo of me vaping in the
bathroom like God it was like at JetBlue
like yeah
I know I know yes no hashtag Blue Chips
I was like hashtag blue like you know I
dare you to rest I dare you to I don't
know I I forgot what I I forgot the
language I used I'd have to find it but
um they're like kind of forgot about
forgot about this sure of course and
then months later I'm at the Burbank
Airport and uh I hear my name multiple
times as I'm as I'm going through
security actually I keep hearing them
say like Brandon Wardell come to gate A9
I hear them say this like three times as
I'm walking from security to the gate
and it's a small airplane yeah so like I
don't know how many times they said it
before that okay
um this is like an hour before my flight
and uh I get up to the gate I'm they're
saying it again and I'm like oh that's
me I'm hey I'm him you thought they
would just reminding you to keep going
yeah I thought they were just
encouraging Brandon Wardell you're doing
great two more gates to go buddy pick up
a sandwich and Guy Fieri's stand so this
guy uh this guy's standing there uh
introduces himself and he goes yeah I'm
uh I'm like head of regional security
for JetBlue Jesus Christ
um you you posted something about
um vaping vaping on you're like I was on
a Xanax yeah and uh I was on a legal
match
basically he was just like uh well I
apparently they tried they tried talking
to me after I landed on that flight and
I just wasn't yeah right he wasn't there
I like had headphones on walk right past
them of course
um and so he he goes uh he's like Hey so
uh if this happens again
um we will divert the aircraft no oh my
God we will divert the aircraft and uh d
d board the plane oh my God and arrest
you you will yeah you'll you will be
arrested banned for many few further uh
any future wow JetBlue flights and our
next conversation will not be so
friendly are we clear you're like this
one wasn't friendly either dude and I
was like yeah yeah no it wasn't really
so thanks for giving me another chance
but what I do appreciate that yeah yeah
they did leave me with a warning right I
agree with you baby
no I now I if I were to do that again in
theory please do not please don't no no
but you no you can Vape in an airplane
bathroom just don't post it and tag the
airline yeah don't tag the airline dude
do you realize you also can't you should
have tagged American Airlines
I know but then I know do you realize if
you did that on Spirit Air they would
have cut you with a box cutter that's
right and that's fine all right fly the
plan yeah uh on December 14th GSP met
with reamers and then went to the
driver's Riverdale home for a knock and
talk what's a knock and talk that I love
so much
you had a knock and talk at the airport
Brandon Wardell please come to gate A9
for knocking time uh while at the home
they spoke with the driver saw the
motorcycle Drive the end the driver
eventually admitted to fleeing of course
you're gonna admit to it what did he do
what it was the crime Chase
pull him over oh yeah we don't even know
what we're charging for yeah he's right
though we don't know what the initial
crime is so he the County Police said
they issued how many arrest warrants
against the driver who has not been
identified it is unclear What charges he
actually faces but how many arrest
warrants does he have
six how could he have more than one he
could I say six I'll go three
uh five get your answers in shout out
your ham radios he has twelve twelves
Jesus so he's got lots of he's done a
lot of bad things so okay so my guess is
they he had an arrest warrant out they
saw his life but whatever they're like
this is our guy and he's like I'm gonna
outrun him but I'm gonna post it on Tick
Tock just like [__] why not how many
hits I wonder how many clicks he got it
didn't say without the diligent efforts
of Lieutenant remors to go above and
beyond the Call of Duty Call of Duty uh
it is highly likely that the offender
would not have been identified he could
have continued to endanger the citizens
of Clayton County Police
applaud the efforts of this [__] yeah
without him dumping a total idiot and
the cops looking down so it's like he's
like you know everybody had a hand in
this including the perpetrator it's my
time to go all right dumb Justice that's
what I like I don't like justice there
you go so there you go there's the show
uh Brandon Wardell thank you again the
podcast that people should check out if
you're the Brandon Jamel show Brandon
Jamel show which I've seen clips of so
funny so funny dude keep doing what
you're doing I love seeing you uh you
got a very bright future on JetBlue
ahead of you we'll see you guys next
time and oh [__] we gotta get back to
work see ya boom stick around
people town
[Music]